hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 10 video so many new
questions even though we got a whole
bunch of big answers so I'll try to
answer everything as well as explain who
the new characters we saw were thank you
everyone for all the nice comments
during my CW of fan talk appearance
we actually got to meet the writer of
last night's flash episode and Emily
BETT recorded a special message so if I
ever do something like that again I'll
totally let you guys know in one of my
videos just so you can watch it so just
careful for spoilers I'm gonna do a
quick rundown of all the new storylines
that they teed up just because those are
really important so we have like
character arts that we need to talk
about we have big moments from the
episode and then we have to talk about
like the big running storylines so in
present day we have story line number
one with team break in the glades
that's gonna be part of the canary
trilogy that's happening brick is gonna
be like the final boss the team arrow or
the new team arrow has to defeat think
of him as like a final boss fight so
they have to fight a bunch of smaller
bosses before they get to him number two
we have flashback Oliver with the China
white bio weapon number three there's
team Merlyn supposedly on the run now or
that that's what they're teasing number
four Ray Palmer finishing his atom suit
and testing it out and then number five
Oliver and present-day being healed by
katana and to say Oh Felicity is kind of
floating around in the moon right now
but I think she's gonna just bounce back
and forth between team arrow and Ray
Palmer just like she's been okay so here
we go top five moments so much to talk
about in this episode but number five
the new team arrow that opening scene
explained everything about what you need
to know about the new team arrow I
thought he was green I thought he was
supposed to be good I love that everyone
always asks about Diggle putting on a
costume and they stuck him in Oliver's
costume he's worn it before if you
remember back in season one when he
needed to throw someone off his scent he
would have Diggle dress up as the arrow
so that he could stand next to said
person and they would see I can't be the
vigilante because he's right there and
I'm right here and I know everyone wants
to know if he's ever gonna get a costume
of his own no I don't think that Diggle
is ever gonna wear his own costume I
don't think he's gonna be Green Lantern
I think he'll just be Diggle like he's
already kind of a superhero but I do
think they'll have a little bit of fun
with it like they did in this episode
where they stick them in other people's
costumes so just for the next couple of
episodes it's just gonna be Roy Diggle
and Black Canary but for the meantime
the three people are just going to be
pursuing
those enforcers that got away until they
get to that final boss fight and have to
take down brickwell himself number four
Merlyn and Thea need to GTFO this was
actually one of the more confusing parts
of the episode Merlyn said they need to
get out obviously because the League of
Assassins is still coming for him
because Oliver's death meant that Merlyn
is still marked for death so it's really
not Thea that's in danger it's just
Merlyn and Merlyn wants to keep her
close there was something really
important that John Barrowman said and
one of the promos that they were posting
last week family is more important than
anything and when Thea was talking about
Oliver
Merlyn said he's family so that makes me
wonder if Merlyn is going to get
involved with the Oliver plot at some
point one of the funniest lines in the
episode though is when Thea said I could
have killed you
and Merlyn smirks and says it's cute
that you think that would be possible
mostly it's just him being a badass but
that you could build a lot of double
meanings into that but if Oliver is
coming back and he's getting healed back
to health obviously they have some sort
of special methods inside the League of
Assassins and katana has some special
skills so maybe Merlyn also has those
special skills which means he's almost
unkillable number three meet danny
brickwell AKA brick from the comics his
back story in the comics is really
mysterious not a lot is known about him
before he showed up in Star City yes he
is a metahuman in the comics he has like
super strong skin so he's almost
indestructible I don't think the arrow
is gonna go that direction I think I
think they'll just explain it that he
has like metal plating in his head
something to just make him tougher I
don't think he's gonna be a full-blown
metahuman on arrow
even though arrow is open to doing
powers on the show he's gonna be taking
over the glades becoming like the new
big crime boss of Star City in the
comics he kind of did the same thing
so after this big event called the
Amsterdam Avenue disaster it's like the
comic book version of the undertaking
from season 1 Malcolm Merlyn and dr.
light just blow up a bunch of bombs all
over Star City now that's the comics
obviously on arrow they do that in
season one with the undertakings just
think of him as rising from the ashes of
the undertaking and just grabbing all
the territory he could the way he's
explained in the comics is his rise to
power isn't tied to his abilities as a
metahuman they just they put him forth
this is really smart criminal but you
can't put Vinnie Jones in a TV show
without letting him punch someone in the
face so there will be
of him fighting people number two Laurel
takes the mantle of the Black Canary
I've seen a lot of questions from you
guys about powers you know how they're
gonna express how they're gonna deal
with her character how they're gonna
show her evolving as a fighter they
haven't said anything about metahuman
abilities but I think them showing the
canary cry bombs on the table kind of
answers that question so she's not gonna
get like her canary cry like she has in
the comics and this canary trilogy is
meant to address her getting better as a
hero so she's gonna get her butt kicked
a lot in these next couple of episodes
eventually she'll get a little bit
better it's the same deal with Roy if
you remember in the beginning of the
episode when he was chasing the
criminals and they were like he's in
he's supposed to be good Roy is gonna
mess a lot of stuff up and so is black
canary so it's not like she's gonna be a
superhero right away she's gonna be more
like a cosplay vigilante I think there's
a little bit confusion about that just
because she gets a superhero costume
doesn't mean that the writers want you
to think that she's a superhero the
really funny thing from behind the
scenes though is that caity lotz was
actually talking about her taking the
mantle about Laurel taking the mantle
she said that Katie Cassidy's wig was
way better than hers she called her
Sarah Wiig more of like a Dolly Parton
wig which i think is kind of funny so
every time I watch old episodes from
season two and see Black Canary
I think of Dolly Parton fighting crime
for those of you that are huge Sarah
fans that are really sad to see her go
she will be back this season in the
canaries episode I think that's either
episode 12 or 13 you know in a flashback
she also goes to a ton of convention so
you can still totally get her autograph
and talk to her about how much you loved
her I think it's interesting though that
Laurel is the one who kind of kicks
everyone in the butt and says you know
are you coming back Diggle we have all
these people we need to catch we can't
let them get away so she is gonna be the
driving force for these next couple of
episodes and catching these people in
that person she took down at the end of
the episode that was the person from the
trial earlier and my number one moment
of course WTF Oliver wakes up this was
like the biggest surprise of the episode
for a number of different reasons one
that they answered the dead not dead
question so fast I thought that we're
gonna leave that question hanging for a
little bit longer I'm glad they answered
it but now they have to answer why he's
not going back right away as for the
katana thing I'll explain this in my
thumbs down a little bit I feel like
she's a bit of a deus ex mashing up
right now I think they had other plans
for the character in the first half of
the season but then the actress that was
gonna play her dropped out
they had to recast her so I think they
had to rewrite a lot of this story so I
think there were a lot of katana scenes
early on they got written out it just we
barely spent any time with her the first
half of the season and all of a sudden
now she's like the most important person
in the world for example the character
that played Ted grant Wildcat he was
cast on another show so they might not
be able to bring him back at all this
season and originally it seemed like
they had bigger plans for the Wildcat
character either way Oliver is alive and
now we get to find out why he doesn't go
back right away that's gonna be the most
fun thing about that this is gonna be
like how long is he's just gonna sit
there and stew in that cabin how much
longer before he lets his friends know
that he's alive here's my big question
for you guys how much time do you think
is gonna go by before Oliver lets his
friends know that he's still alive
there's a couple of ways that could go
down he could surprise everyone in like
a big hero moment like in a big fight
with brick or some other big villain or
to someone else could let them know that
Oliver is still alive okay so here are
the really big character arts that I
think are gonna be happening because
some of the characters will be changing
quite a bit starting off with Roy so Roy
obviously we saw him with the drink in
that hand I think he's totally gonna go
alcoholic if you remember in the comics
he became a heroin addict I feel like
that is going to be what this storyline
is it's gonna be his downward slope it's
even like the Laurel storyline in season
2 where Laurel started popping pills and
started drinking too much I'm hoping
that Laurel will actually help save him
it just seems like her being a
recovering alcoholic will recognize that
happening in someone else and she'll
help them
Laurel of course pretty easy to see
where her character arc is going she's
gonna take the mantle the Black Canary
learn to be a superhero over X amount of
time it's gonna be an ongoing process I
mean Oliver is still learning to be a
superhero and he's been at it for five
years longer than any of the other
characters Diggle is gonna take more of
a leadership role I mean he's like the
old man on the team now so naturally he
has more experience than all of them
Felicity kind of blowing in the wind
still waiting to see where she lands but
I do I do think she'll come back and
she'll start helping in Ray Palmer of
course gonna finish building his atom
suit then test it out
Merlyn and Thea are actually pretty
interesting there have been some
pictures of her with like that mystery
DJ character so it sounds like she might
not be leaving Starling city regardless
of what Merlyn does I'm really curious
to see where their plot will intersect
with team arrow and the Oliver plot like
often Nanda Parbat family is more
important than anything
just think of that whenever you're
thinking of Merlin and then we have
Oliver in present day obviously he's
going to heal himself get better come
back during that CW a fan's hawk one of
the writers actually said that he might
be having some dreams too so we might
get a lot of all of her dream sequences
as he's healing
they also said not all those dreams are
gonna be good so he's probably gonna be
having some crazy nightmares all the
stunts were great totally amazing they
really gave all the good stunts they
would normally get into Stephen Amell to
Colton Haynes so Colton is like the new
Stephen Amell on the show at least until
Oliver comes back there were a couple
thumbs down I had so first was the
courtroom scenes I feel like they don't
really need to do courtroom scenes they
could have done those in the police
station and just save time they wouldn't
had to cast all those extras they just
wanted to set up that moment for the end
where Black Canary could take down that
criminal from the courtroom scene and
then the katana plot which I kind of
mentioned she doesn't really feel like a
full character right now it feels like
they didn't spend enough time with her
in the first half of the season I think
a lot of that is just due to logistical
problems it's always interesting to see
like the plans producers make at the
beginning of the season and then see
what finally ends up getting shot like
what ends up turning up in the actual
episodes all in all great episode strong
and opener I like the way they opened
this episode and the flash like both
with people like screaming through the
frame like right as the episode started
so you have like the flash running right
through the frame and then you had the
car just running right through at the
beginning of arrow so I'll be posting
next week's episodes right after the
episodes there I don't have any podcast
planned or anything like that so it'll
be more like my normal schedule be sure
to subscribe to get everything I will be
posting a Q&A for this on Thursday
though so if you have any specific
questions you want me the answer just
leave them in the comments I also saw
some news about Suicide Squad supposedly
Jake Gyllenhaal has turned down the role
that Tom Hardy dropped out of that was
the rick flagg character so any of you
who hated the idea of Jake Gyllenhaal on
Suicide Squad it sounds like you won't
have to worry and people asking about my
latest last airbender episode I actually
I had because I had to go on the CW a
fan talk today I had a little less time
to get it out so I'll push that out as
soon as possible right after this and
thank you again everyone that came on
and said really nice things in the chat
I saw a lot of like emergency awesome
tags like in the CW a fan cast chat is
it was really cool speaking of that if
you guys want to you can now submit
fansubs on this video all you have to do
is just go into like the the subs menu
and you can
like add you can add your native
language in case you haven't seen it yet
you can click here for my flash episode
from last night and click here to learn
more about what's gonna be happening on
arrow this season thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five I'll see
you guys tonight
you